would be a good approach to effectively
what would be a good approach to
effectively leading a team where instead
of taking ownership of their
responsibilities and working towards
team goals each team member is just
trying to be the boss
okay so a couple things here you want to
let them be the boss of their tasks
right that's what you're trying to do so
that that makes sense and one of the
ways if they're if they want to be the
boss of everything maybe you give them a
little bit more as much decision-making
process that you can as to what tasks or
what projects they're in charge of so
that makes them feel a little bit like
they're empowered and I shouldn't say
makes them feel like they're empowered
you actually are Ramallah you know what
I mean so there's a there's a pretty
significant distinction because once
again people will recognize if you're
just letting them do it to make them
feel good about it they're gonna know
that yeah okay Jocko thanks for the
decision you gave me a choice of one
thing thank you the color pants yeah so
so you know maybe let them really
express their authority and leadership
on owning what it is that they're owning
it but the question says they're not
taking ownership of their
responsibilities so let's make sure
first that we're not that we're giving
them full rein and full ownership of
their responsibilities and we're not
micromanaging in there now if that if
we're beyond that and and we got people
that just want to be in charge of a
whole thing mm-hmm well cool that's
that's actually awesome you want to be
in charge of everything if that goes is
it our team and he wants to be in charge
of everything hey guys check it out
right now this next you know project
that we're working EKKO is gonna run it
I'm gonna sit back and by the way next
project bill you're running mmm and next
project Fred you're running now we're
all gonna get to actually get in the hot
seat and I'll tell you what you're gonna
see number one you're gonna see some
people that go mmm they wanted to sit in
the back and chirp but they don't really
want to be responsible for anything so
that puts them to rest right away you're
also what's gonna happen with everybody
is they're all gonna see that this thing
that looks so easy from the back of the
room is a lot harder than they think
that's what it's like running a seal
mission the guy in the back that's never
been in charge before is it go we should
do it like this yeah and that guy okay
here you run this and then you know in
six hours they come up and say hey could
you give me a hand with how you're
supposed to contact a deconflict with
these other units okay it's a little
trickier than you thought maybe isn't it
but you you actually put people in
charge of things if they want to be in
charge of things put them in charge of
things it's great and you know don't let
them fall on her face don't let them get
anyone Killed don't let them you know
get anyone injured or lose any strategic
ground we're not gonna do that but we're
gonna let them have the opportunity to
step up and lead if they do a good job
sweet yeah sweet now you've got them you
can rely on them you can actually put
them in charge the projects now you
don't the micromanagement have to watch
over them this is this is a no-lose
situation this happened actually one of
my one of my platoon was going through
training and one of the platoon
commanders came up to me we're just
putting them pulling up a tune through
training and he comes up knees Oh Mike
platoon chief wants to run everything
and I said good let him run everything
let him run everything that's perfect
then you can focus on you know other
things don't worry about it but ego
right we want to be running everything
we want that we I'm the guy in charge
yeah no let him run it and it's just
it's it's it's the the reason the thing
that holds people back from letting
other people run things is insecurity
hmm if I think echos gonna do a better
job than me or I think you're gonna do a
really good job and you're gonna shine
and I don't feel like I do a good job
I'm gonna hold you back as the best of
my ability ya know I go uh you go ahead
you go ahead and just stay in your lane
okapis over here you know but if I if I
if I know if I'm securing my leadership
man echo oh you want to run this dude
awesome
here you go here's the plan once you
know here's the here's the portfolio why
don't you put the plan together I'm
gonna be over here looking down the road
on the next project and looking for our
next thing down the road going out and
getting another client to bring into the
game we're gonna make this happen no
factor yeah seems like counterintuitive
isn't it yeah it is you wanna you want
me to say here's how you keep the people
in their lanes yes I'm gonna tell you
what you do let him out of their lanes
let him into your lane let him run some
stuff you build a new leader it's a
beautiful thing
when you you know when you're insecure
you want you don't want them to shout
out shine you you know you can tell that
where I think it's natural though you
know when people may be a little
insecure you know or if you're not as
good as maybe you hope or well I think
it's natural to be a little bit insecure
of course here's how here's how
in my experience anyway where I could
tell where I'm being insecure where if
someone's performing a certain thing and
you're kind of like you can feel it
consciously you kind of hope that they
don't do that good yeah
but saying that I know that's bad it's
bad but that's how you can tell yeah
that's a gator tell if you have that
feeling oh you should you should
definitely you if you have that feeling
check yourself yeah you know what here I
am hoping that my own team member ain't
no job yeah that's that's a bad
situation real bad you want to hope
everyone's doing great
yeah and you know this happened on
deployment and I talked about it in the
book extreme ownership was you know the
Delta platoon commander he was worried
that this element that had come into
work in his AO he was worried that they
were gonna be better than him and take
his job and he told me that and I said
hey bro if they take your job good I'll
find a new job for you if there's so
much work we got work to do don't worry
about it help them help them take your
job yeah and I'll find you a new job it
turns out that their egos were too big
and they couldn't let that happen
but that's the same situation you got
somebody that thinks gonna take your job
and do better than you help them and
then find new work yeah
because because we're trying to help the
team right there's a mission there's an
overall mission and if echo can do
something better than me
hey here's the turnover here's the
lessons I learned you'd better at this
than I am
you keep running with it I'm gonna go
find something that I'm good at or an
area that I can help that's just
supporting the whole team that's the
land right yeah yes so and you know what
sitting in the podcast studio it's so
easy to talk about that yeah but it's so
hard for people to do that it really is
really yeah so one of those things where
you're dealing with your actual feelings
in the situation we're not dealing with
our acts
right now but which but it doesn't that
mean that it's that's good you know
you're giving a fresh like view you yeah
you know you are detached
I am the yeah an accurate advice and the
more detached and you pointed out some
red flags right if I'm hoping that these
guys go on the mission and fail that's a
red flag that you're being selfish and
insecure about your job and what you're
doing
and if someone can do a job better than
you let them do it
mmm that's gonna help the whole team
yeah so it's like you're us in the
podcast room we're like you know if you
get a guy in the maze the maze of
emotions and we're outside of the mains
on top we can see the whole maze we're
not in the maze of emotions we're on top
we can look at the whole scenario the
whole maze so we can tell that guy what
to do effectively yes no echo you just
described attachment there you go that's
what the attachment is like that that's
what that's what laughs that's what it's
like for me yeah I can see the maze and
I remember learning how to step back and
step above and look at the maze I
remember yeah remember learning that and
going oh that's all you got to do yeah
and then I remember taking it from the
training ground the battlefield and then
realizing that that's what you need to
do in the everyday interactions with
people and especially once I got in the
business world that I the thing that was
cool about when we started echelon front
now I would be witnessing like we I'd go
into a meeting and I would be detached I
would be up above the maze of emotions
in turmoil and so now I would get to see
it and then I would start bringing the
leadership and saying look at what this
looks like to me yeah they'd go cool I
don't like that one - the video - yeah
go into the video and and so then that's
how you learn we didn't go to the video
look what it looks like from up above
the maze and now you see you see what
you were doing here in your meeting you
had everybody so intimidated that no one
said anything you just gave a 15 minute
meeting no one responded in any way to
anything you said you think everyone in
that room agreed with everything you
said not a chance
they didn't say work why is that you
intimidated him you bullied them and now
you're not getting any feedback and
they're gonna execute the plan that they
don't believe in and that's probably
less effective than the one that they
have coming from the
yeah congratulations congratulations
no-knock congratulations let's get this
opposite of congratulation like you know
so I was in the in traffic and something
to think about I was in traffic and you
know how that you have the two lanes
right so I'm gonna turn left on the
light yeah in the lane next to me
they're going straight so whoever the
person in front of the person that was
next to me both going straight they were
taking to them so the lady next on
getting the horn like this all crazy so
of course I look over at and she's going
crazy she looks over at me she's like
like do you believe this kind of thing
all by nuts meanwhile I'm looking at
myself you know other people around me
they're just like well this lady's going
nuts
you know so that's an example of being
on the outside looking in her she
thought it was justifiable honking the
horn looking nuts but meanwhile we're on
the outside looking at her like bad you
know you look and you know what that
situation is you didn't have anywhere to
be she did well then I read like she's
you know you know I'm saying though
she's a person that hadn't left for late
work late and she was gonna be in
trouble and blah blah blah and that that
30 set that that 10 sec that eight
seconds yeah it was probably like it was
an eternity for her yeah she's just
going nuts just like I was talking about
in the airport if I'm running late for
the flight tsa takes five minutes it
could be no factor or it could drive me
completely insane
you know and that's those her and you
know what these days when I screw
something up I don't get frustrated like
that you know that's what we're talking
about the first question oh my god I
agree I look at myself and god I can't
believe I left late yeah do this I'm I'm
an idiot yeah I won't let that happen
again
I said that in 1996 and I haven't had to
let it happen
[Music]
sumino I was outside the main thing I
know how she's feeling
mmm guys not going go green light go
it's time to go universal yeah so I
understand the feeling but look how you
look from the outside you know did she
check herself at all not when she saw
you know she looked at to me for some
emotional support yeah as if you believe
this guy you know get crazy with me kind
of thing that was the look yeah man it's
like dig it that's what I think that's
another uh understand the difference
between feeling and behavior as well you
know like I feel I know that's a
frustrating thing it can be
but don't behave like that calm down